je voudrais saluer le strict respect des
consignes de confinement par la très
grande majorité des français
contrairement à ce que l'on entend
parfois ici ou là la france a adopté des
règles de confinement parmi les plus
sévères d'europe
elle l'a fait tôt face à la vague
épidémique et ces mesures sont dans
l'ensemble très bien respectée ceux qui
ne respectent pas les règles du
confinement sont peu nombreux et ils
seront sévèrement punis car il en va de
la santé de tous et notamment des plus
fragiles d'entre nous nous avons dit à
plusieurs reprises aux français que le
confinement devrait durer aussi
longtemps que nécessaire pour casser la
vague épidémique et pour permettre à nos
hôpitaux de faire face dans toute la
mesure du possible à l'afflux de cas
sévère causée par le cos vide 19 au
terme de ces dix premiers jours de
confinement
il est clair que nous n'en sommes encore
qu'au début de la vague épidémique est
là c'est vrai submergé le grand test
depuis plusieurs jours elle arrive en
ile-de-france et dans les hauts de
france
c'est pourquoi avec l'accord du
président de la république
j'annonce aujourd'hui le renouvellement
de la période de confinement pour deux
semaines supplémentaires à compter de
mardi prochain soit jusqu'au mercredi 15
avril les mêmes règles que celles
actuellement en vigueur continueront à
s'appliquer cette période pourra
évidemment être prolongée si la
situation sanitaire l'exigé
si et seulement si la situation
sanitaire l'exigent
vous savez que le conseil scientifique
qui éclairent les décisions du
gouvernement évalue à au moins six
semaines au global la période totale de
confinement il est encore trop tôt pour
le savoir avec certitude c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'annonce cette décision
je remercie une nouvelle fois les
français pour leur civisme pour leur
patience et pour leur solidarité
nous en avons besoin dans ces temps
difficiles
et comme je l'aï indiqué plus tôt dans
la journée
je vous donne rendez vous demain avec le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
pour un point complet sur la situation
du pays
face à cette épidémie je vous remercie
et je passe la parole à madame la
porte-parole douleur du gouvernement